the Joe Rogan experience they were
saying did you see that tweet I thought
maybe was a freaking wood or something
like that he was like oh J will be doing
stand-up in three months dude do you
watch those videos know it why do you
why do we attain that she loved it
fastly love it too I just untangle over
the world there's a lot of BS out there
he does videos on Twitter Instagram know
he thinks Twitter is bad Thanks
he's holding his reading glasses in his
hand I mean he's going blind he's 71
years old you just see the the the DME
sent that dude amazing with all the but
you understand that with strategic right
he sent that on monday monday was the
25th anniversary of the [ __ ] Bronco
chase so you think that he didn't just
want to be in the news like that was all
I was I was a strategic move I don't
think he's not smart I think what's
going on is he reacting to someone
[ __ ] with him and he doesn't he
doesn't know how to just let [ __ ] slide
so somebody makes a parody video where
he's doing his Twitter there's a Hello
Twitter world and then someone's got how
please in the back and who DMS that
person who made that video I'm gonna cut
you I don't think he said I'm gonna cut
yeah yeah yeah a strategic man I think
he knew it was the 25th anniversary of
Bronco chase and OJ's only relevant is
the fact that he got away with murder so
he has to remind us of that fact all the
time in order for us to give a [ __ ] did
you ever see the videos he did when he
was doing rap when he was dressing up
like King in Miami yeah he dressed like
a rapper
yeah no no yet Jamie yeah we can't we
can't play around off YouTube real quick
that stuff was fake that Dan what's up
they actually like broke it down
instantly he made in a fake account with
like it was the real OJ he just made the
L a capital I
I gave him donkey today for no [ __ ]
reason yeah I'm glad I'm glad he's not
that stupid donkey today ii are not
doing The Breakfast Club I give somebody
the credit they deserve it being stupid
I'm like yeah you can't be that stupid
that thirsty for attention Oh J so it's
kind of it's kind of a relief that he's
not that thirsty
this is Oh J when he was doing rap music
alright no no we can't and now he is
yeah we can't play the music but he had
girls out there dancing around their
underwear and the oj was rapping didn't
he have like a crown on or something
there is dressed up in like white face
and all sorts of things naked girls in
it oh god you don't think Oh J been
riding away with killing these two
people for too long well crazy [ __ ]
will still [ __ ] him bro he's insane I
don't understand this this this part of
women at all like the women that like
meet people in jail and then they like
get married to them in joy yeah look
what is this about it's about the jail
dick when they come home some of those
guys never get to give him that jail
dick they're in jail forever and they
get no conjugal visits and they still
want to marry him but they're why are
attracted to killers so they want
killers they want killers and
specifically they want killers that kill
women what yeah that's a thing with some
women with really [ __ ] up women they
they're attracted to men who kill women
okay what happen the girls want to get
choked do you think do you think all the
choking and like you know how like some
girls have a great fantasies do you
think that's all because men have just
become such [ __ ] they want to see if
they have the ability to even do it no I
think some girls have this primal need
to know that you can kill them but know
that this thing turns them on right
protect them is that Caleb yeah for sure
but they want to know you could kill
them not that you're going to kill them
or get someone else trying to get them
that's that hand on your neck yeah Tokyu
they want to be like close to the door
of you doing something vile to them
while you're [ __ ] them so it feels
good why you got control over their life
you really have like you're holding
their Nazis control right no so why do
we
you know these dudes that like jerk off
with like a belt on their neck and check
that we call them weirdos it's just
women yeah but that's different this
that's auto-erotic asphyxiation it is
but I think the choking is you're doing
it a man is doing it to you it's not
just that you're running out of oxygen
because someone's squeezing the blood
out of your brain right but it's also
that someone's doing it to you while
your mother-fucking do you guys go for
the whole choke cuz what I do is I like
put my hand there and then I kind of
just tense my forearm but I don't really
squeeze the fingers cuz I want you know
cuz like that she won't let me do that
she wants the whole choke no she doesn't
like that oh she doesn't like that she
knows you could do it well it's not just
that it's like she sees you choke people
out regularly she knows you're capable
but the kind of girl that wants you to
choke her like that I think you should
leave that one alone dude my wife like
the little children we've got no did all
of that stuff has kind of like subsided
but she's like a lot of choking we even
got 22 years yeah but I think it's
really because they see men as pathetic
now they see men as babies and the more
pathetic and like cooked up a guy is
they're like okay choke me slapped me
around show me that you have some
testosterone show me you have some sort
of strain gotta go give ol Jason Placido
no choke him Richard Ramirez to have
girls visiting him Manson that was
married but he died Manson had charm he
must have had something no he must have
had fame fame has always been in a trap
he wasn't famous in the beginning when
he was getting people to do all that
wild [ __ ] he was in man bit Manson right
well he wasn't famous but he was a cult
leader so right so he was the leader of
a small group so he was infamous
infamous amongst that group of people
yeah you gotta at least turn a couple
people to turn it into a cult like
eventually it becomes part of it but if
you look at social media you realize
that any really [ __ ] right and a really
[ __ ] to have a following you know I'm
saying 500 followers on social media is
pathetic right but 500 in real life yo
Hugh the man Jim Jones especially in 67
yeah
you get 10 people - you get 10 people to
kill yourself in 67
[Applause]